you went to a school really interesting
School the Michaela Community School in
North London run by this fascinating
head teacher Catherine berbil Singh who
runs a pretty tough school but has
amazing results at this school and as a
result of you going she got bombarded
without from people and she took it on
head on actually and went yeah I'm sorry
we're going to keep inviting people with
all different views all different types
of people and that's going to include
people like Jordan Peterson she owned it
and she was proud that you went to her
school tell me about that visit what do
you think of her as well well people
think of her school as tough and that
she's this Dragon Lady and that isn't
what I saw what I saw was that she was
playing a very sophisticated game with
her students and games have rules
and if you don't enforce the rules then
the game doesn't play properly and every
game has a referee because someone has
to enforce the rules and she's a very
very sophisticated referee and she's
playing an unbelievably sophisticated
game and the students are so alert and
on target
their attention is so well regulated by
themselves like for example when we
walked into her classrooms we walked
into about seven we were LED round by
three relatively small kids who were
very articulate and together and
attentive and polite and focused when we
walked into her classes the students
didn't
turn their eyes away from their teacher
to look at us there was no buzz of
conversation they were just focused on
their teacher and their teacher was
focused too it's like we could walk in
and the whole thing just continued
around us and that was really something
to see and fast-paced man the teachers
were spitting out information as fast as
I've ever heard anyone spit out
information and the students were
reacting like just like just like it was
choreographed and the truth is it works
I mean recently this school that's
annoying yeah right it's annoying for
those who immediately howl this is
disgusting these poor kids oh yeah 80 of
the students achieve four plus C or more
in their GCSE is a very good results
despite being non-selective right that's
a big deal a huge deal
and yet she gets castigated for it which
says to me that my sort of gut feeling
that we've just gone a bit soft enough
it's annoying when you help out the
victims because then there's no one to
be like narcissistically compassionate
about them so and that's certainly the
situation she's in yeah it's quite
amazing that she's managed this with
with kids who are a non-selected sample
and I asked her you know well how many
kids do you have to expel let's say for
serious misbehavior and she said it's
only been a tiny handful and I said well
how many kids can't adjust to the more
rigorous pace and she said well they
they can all adjust and that's what I
saw I mean I never saw I never saw a
bunch of children a group of children
that were more focused and alert than I
saw at that school and it was really
part trending in some sense by you going
there they people actually reported her
to the police for a hate crime yeah just
by your presence in that school that's
the problem with hate crime legislations
like who defines hate and I know the
answer to that who defines hate the
people you lease want to
so you know you want hate crime
legislation you just better keep in mind
who's going to Define what constitutes
hate and then you think about the people
you're enabling these rat Finks these
people who didn't learn not to uh
tattletail on their peers when they were
children who run to totalitarian
authority to wield their resentful power
now that's all part of the legal code
it's like well we'll see where that goes
well we know where it goes It goes so
that you know
demented half-wit resentful narcissists
can rat out Kate herbal sing to the
police yes yeah well that's not good not
at all and who knows where it'll end up